[Musica]
vorrei portarvi con me in un viaggio nel
tempo per farlo vi racconterò tre storie
nella prima siamo assenti john una
cittadina nell'isola canadesi di
terranova è il 12 dicembre 1901 le 12 e
30 un giovane italiano di 27 anni sede
fiducioso ad aspettare che un segnale
radio partito da 3.400 chilometri di
distanza da aldo in cornovaglia
raggiunga la sua stazione ricevente
l'esperimento non può funzionare è
impossibile secondo gli scienziati più
competenti e dell'epoca infatti un
segnale radio non può superare una
distanza di 300 chilometri ma il nostro
giovane italiano è convinto che il
segnale radio possa rimbalzare
sfruttando la conducibilità della
superficie terrestre ma non ha ragione
però l'esperimento funziona funziona
perché a 100 chilometri d'altezza
esiste una fascia di atomi molecole
cariche di elettricità ionizzate si dice
lei ono sfera che consenta il segnale
radio di rimbalzare seguire quindi la
sfericità del nostro pianeta
guglielmo marconi ricevette il 9 per la
fisica e fu nominato senatore del regno
ora siamo nizza il 4 luglio 1807 quasi
un secolo prima una famiglia in festa
perché è nato giuseppe un bambino che
fin dalla tenera età si dimostra curioso
coraggioso pieno di voglia di fare in
tenera età inizia a solcare i mari
si narra che abbia salvato 12 persone da
un probabile annegamento ma quando
compie vent'anni che si innamora degli
ideali di libertà e indipendenza che in
quel periodo in europa soffiano forti
dopo le sconfitte di napoleone per
questo si arruola molto giovane
accanto a rivoluzionare in uruguay in
brasile ma nel 1848 torna in italia
nel pino degli scontri con l'austria per
il sogno di un'italia unita e
indipendente 6 maggio 1860 quarto genova
giuseppe garibaldi conduce la
leggendaria spedizione dei mille
sbarca marsala e dall'inizio la sua
marcia trionfale e resto è storia
la nostra terza storia ci porta in
algeria nel 2003 il fotografo gerome di
lei cattura nel momento nel quale
quattro uomini sollevano una bambina di
due anni dalle macerie di un devastante
terremoto riconsegnando era la vita la
bambina emily caidi guarda verso l'alto
per due giorni nel buio più totale sole
disperata ha continuato a chiamare sua
madre e grazie a queste urla che
volontari spagnoli l'hanno trovata
riconsegnata la vita
nel quadro di questa immagine il
terrificante terremoto che ha ucciso
oltre 1400 algerini è solo un piccolo
ingrediente la protagonista è la vita
la faccia è l'espressione di emily ci
raccontano di come lei sia pronta a
rinascere in questo mondo che la quasi
seppellita i successi di guglielmo
marconi le gesta di giuseppe garibaldi
in nome della libertà e
dell'indipendenza del nostro paese
il trionfo della vita di amy lee cosa
hanno in comune queste tre storie
all'apparenza così lontane tra di loro
lo scopriremo insieme ma prima torniamo
nell'italia del 2021
si parla e si legge molto di futuri ci
facciamo molte domande sul futuro
infatti che tempo farà domani come sarà
l'economia nel prossimo anno che lavoro
faremo 13 anni è nella natura dell'uomo
farsi domande sul futuro
a parte proprio della nostra evoluzione
pensiamo al futuro per programmare le
azioni che servono per andare in quel
futuro e come lo facciamo
studi più recenti hanno dimostrato che
per immaginare il futuro
usiamo le stesse aree del cervello che
utilizziamo per pensare al passato siamo
bravi a costruire con quello che
conosciamo già
ma in un presente come quello attuale
così accelerato complesso percepiamo che
il futuro sarà qualcosa di completamente
diverso dal passato e questo ci crea
ansia insicurezza quasi l'incapacità di
vedere oltre
e al giorno d'oggi colpiti da questa
terrificante pandemia
le domande sul futuro sono ancora più
forte impellenti e abbiamo ancor più
bisogno di schemi nuovi e di una
narrazione collettiva che ci consenta di
programmare visitare futuri nuovi e
gestire le azioni necessarie per andare
verso questi futuri
ci sono attività umane che più di altri
ci indicano la visione di mondo e la
visione di futuro che abbiamo la ricerca
l'urbanistica l'architettura ma
soprattutto l'educazione
queste sono attività umane che nella
loro progettazione richiedono di avere
una visione chiara di futuro lungo
periodo ma sono anche quelle attività
umane che se ben progettate consentono
di plasmare il futuro che ci aspetta di
fronte a noi
ma qual è la situazione della scuola nel
nostro paese
l'abbandono scolastico e al 13.5 per
cento più alta della media europea
l'abbandono universitario al 24 per
cento negli ultimi 12 anni oltre 200
mila laureati e laureate hanno
abbandonato il nostro paese ma
l'educazione è troppo importante per la
crescita personale per la crescita di
una comunità
e se vogliamo un paese che cresca coeso
accogliente multiculturale l'educazione
e la formazione sono i pilastri sui
quali costruire ma non con l'obiettivo
di creare persona è capace a lavorare
nel futuro dobbiamo prima porci la
domanda qual è l'obiettivo di fondo di
un sistema educativo
io credo che un sistema educativo serva
a dare gli strumenti per comprendere il
mondo e per vivere appieno e col massimo
grado di libertà di crescita possibile
il futuro se impariamo a leggerlo ci
manda dei segnali ci dice quali saranno
le caratteristiche del mondo che verrà
e allora ci racconta il futuro che le
sue caratteristiche saranno l'incertezza
l'accelerazione tecnologica informativa
a crescente complessità globale quindi
interconnesso ad alto contenuto
tecnologico e come possiamo prepararci a
un mondo con queste caratteristiche
possiamo fornire ai nostri giovani gli
strumenti necessari per andare in questa
direzione
e se sì quali sono questi strumenti
l'unesco ha definita la competenza
chiave la scheepers critica thinking che
potremmo definire il senso del futuro
dei futuri ossia come gli scenari futuri
possono influenzare le nostre vite oggi
ma come noi possiamo influenzare gli
scenari futuri leggere e scrivere il
futuro è questo il centro del modello
educativo che assieme a cristina pozzi
mia socia mi propongo di sviluppare è un
nuovo paradigma culturale ed educativo
per un approccio diverso al sistema
educativo del nostro paese per
consentire a chiunque anche più i
giovani di immaginare e scrivere proprio
futuro e come si fa
si inizia ribaltando i curricula
mettendo al centro le competenze e le
esperienze e meno le nozioni
e sviluppando alcune competenze che oggi
non lo sono particolarmente sviluppate
lo spirito critico la filosofia la
collaborazione tra studenti tra docenti
e insegnanti
il pensiero computazionale linguaggio
dei computer
l'arte le lingue straniere gli sport il
gross mindset non sono a cosa la imparo
lo spirito imprenditoriale la capacità
di fallire provare e farlo divertendosi
cercando di rafforzare le materie
scientifiche ma senza toglierle da un
percorso comune a quelle umanistiche
perché le une hanno bisogno delle altre
anche nei percorsi delle scuole
superiori e universitarie non creando
distinzioni tra chi ce la fa e chi non
ce la fa ma guardando chi sta dietro e
cambiando anche il sistema di
valutazione dando meno importanza
all'esame alle valutazioni e più alla
crescita personale e in questo
ovviamente supportando anche i docenti
con metodi e approcci innovativi avere
l'obiettivo di creare i cittadini del
futuro persone che stiano bene in una
situazione di benessere psicofisico
i cittadini del futuro non il capitale
lavoro del futuro
se vogliamo migliorare il nostro paese
questo è più grande regalo che possiamo
fare allo stesso e alla nostra
democrazia e con un sistema educativo di
questo tipo possono accadere delle cose
meravigliose
possiamo immaginare futuri diversi
possiamo imparare cose nuove
completamente nuove quelle che servono
in questi futuri e possiamo realizzare i
futuri che abbiamo immaginato possiamo
alimentare il sentimento più prezioso la
speranza e come emily che anche nel buio
più totale non ha perso la speranza
anzi
è proprio nel buio più totale che
dobbiamo e possiamo avere speranza
perché nel buio più totale nell'ignoto
possiamo prendere una strada nuova non
segnato da qualcun altro per noi è come
giuseppe garibaldi che per la speranza
di un paese unito indipendente ha
combattuto è stato sconfitto esiliato e
poi ha vinto e come guglielmo marconi
che per anni ha sperimentato nella
solitudine della sua casa incompreso
spesso anche deriso prima di veder
riconosciuto i suoi successi
la storia la storia non avanza in modo
graduale ma scossoni a balzi a volte una
persona e spero movimento quello fanno
le sue parole decenni dopo
a volte un gruppo di persone ispirata
vincono e creano un cambiamento forte
nella storia seguite da un movimento di
massa a volte noi stessi che dobbiamo
salvare è questo quello che unisce le
nostre tre storie la speranza
l'immagine di un futuro la speranza e la
speranza quindi non è come un biglietto
della lotteria la speranza richiede
azione e l'azione impossibile senza
speranza ma non solo per le grandi
storie anche per l'amico ol'amica il
nostro vicino di casa che per il suo
sogno particolare la sua visione piccolo
grande che sia positiva di futuro un
nuovo lavoro
un'attività imprenditoriale imparare una
nuova lingua imparare e migliorarsi
nello sport ha lavorato duramente ha
girato il mondo ha sacrificato
valorizzato gli anni migliori della sua
vita o il suo tempo libero per
realizzare un sogno speranze azione il
futuro non è già scritto
ma in qualche modo si autorealizza il
2050 che ci aspetta
e forse diverso da come ce lo
immaginiamo ma è sicuramente quello per
il quale poniamo le condizioni di agire
e agiamo oggi rendere la vita ricca e
piena di significati per questo dobbiamo
garantire il diritto alla speranza non
solo per i giovani non solo perché
vediamo in situazione di difficoltà ma
per chiunque di noi anche in solitudine
anche non visto anche in silenzio si
affrontando momento di crisi
ciascuno di noi è molto di più di quello
che oggi può immaginare ognuno di noi ha
il diritto di essere guardato con occhi
diversi e proporrà se stesso un futuro
diverso per questo garantire il diritto
alla speranza è il più grande regalo che
possiamo fare alla nostra democrazia e
al nostro futuro
grazie